Jay I've got to say I've lived and
worked in Los Angeles for nearly 20
years my number one bucket
list of the whole time I've been here
has been to get inside your it's not
like I didn't invite you I invited you
dozens of time so it's not like you're
like oh no I don't want come oh yeah
yeah okay but well well thanks for I got
to say you walk in we're going to go on
a little walk and talk with your cars
later but but just to walk into this is
a quite extraordinary thing I have never
seen a car ction like this anywhere in
the world well there's plenty of car
collections like I just buy what I like
it's the more money than brains Club
there's really no theme here it's not
Italian cars or the Renaissance you know
it's none of that it's just just things
I like cars of historical or technical
interest and you know it's fun you know
when you work with your hands it
appreciates how easy it is to make money
just talking you know because you take a
transmission like ah some guy made 80
bucks for this and then you go on say oh
plus I think it it it makes you
appreciate iate Show Business a little
bit more you know in what way well I
always tell a story I I'm not going to
say who it is I had a famous movie star
in my show and during the commercial
breaks in the show he's asking about
cars go hey what's I want to get sports
car what a good sports car I said well
you know new Ferrari came out was pretty
unbelievable and he went you know
everybody's got a Ferrari I said okay
now first of all everybody do not a
Ferrari I said get out of Beverly Hills
okay just get out if you ever said that
publicly you be I said most people have
never even seen a Ferrari You' be beaten
in the streets to say most and he
realized how ridiculous it sounded but
that's what happen when you live here so
when you work on things it makes you
appreciate okay you know the reality of
what they actually are yeah exactly this
is going to where on the day of the Iowa
caucus which is the the kickart of the
American presidential election you've
often been described as Mr America
someone who understands both the coasts
uh La New York very well you're
obviously from New York you've lived and
worked here for many years but you also
understand Middle America and the car
collection and the fact you work on
these cars you is a blue collar thing
albeit on a magnificent scale what do
you make of the state of America right
now well I I don't find it I'm way more
optimistic than most people uh you know
you have to look at things I think if
you go back 80 years 90 years something
like 40 50% of the world was starving
now it's 1% maybe I mean when I was a
kid You' see pictures of African bafan
children with the ribs showing and you
know people are you don't really have
that anymore I'm not saying people
aren't going hungry but not the mass
starvation that we used to have so I
mean there are a lot of good things that
happen people are living a lot longer a
lot healthier there are fewer Wars and
so on by almost every metric actually
this is the best time in recorded
history to be alive I think so I always
use shark attacks as my thing because I
remember one year shark attacks up 100%
100 oh my god well there were three last
year and there were six this year I mean
and that's worldwide and you go okay but
if you put it in those terms oh my God
it just sounds like sharks kids get out
of the pool you know you just frighten
to death the sharks so that's the world
we live in you know uh in the old days
media used to be you know I always use
the uh the Rodney King is my there are
two things I used Rodney King and
Princess Diana but Rodney
King if people remember the original
story was on the news uh a Hyundai with
like seven African-Americans were going
115 miles an hour and were arrested by
the police whatever and then I think
name was George holiday he stood on his
balcony and he filmed this and and now
in the old days you take your film to
the news editor you go oh this is too
inflammatory we can't show this to the
public for example when I was a kid in
the Boston Globe nobody was ever raped
women were accosted so that could be
anything from to somebody physically
attacking them you know because you just
didn't want to get the eye of the public
up you know uh now you get your news
unfiltered you know and that's the thing
when when when he showed that Rodney
King footage raw without going through
an editor editing out the the brutal
beating part of it because it would just
be too much for people to take
okay it was shocking but it wasn't the
first time it happened I mean when I was
a did you ever hear of a pedophile when
you were young I I never did why why
wouldn't you take candy from a stranger
what's the big deal well now I mean I go
home and press Megan's list and it's
like oh my God all they're everywhere do
Dr Phil told interesting thing that when
he was you know young in in the 50s if
and he gave an example if somebody was
attacked by a crocodile on a golf course
in rural Florida the chances of anyone
even in that area knowing about it were
very slim because the way to disseminate
news was so restricted you have maybe
one National News Bulletin on the
television you might have a state
newspaper a national newspaper whereas
today young people all around the world
within half an hour will be likely
watching a video from a camera cell
phone right a camera of the of the
crocodile attacking the person and maybe
eating that person on the golf course
and it's that constant overload of
dopamine right right sensory damaging
sensory stuff exactly what you're
talking about which I think is partly
responsible for this kind of epidemic of
anxiety amongst young people because
there's no escape from this stuff but
you don't want to restrict Free Speech
either or or or you know it's so funny
when I was a kid they said oh with
cameras big brother will be watching
everywhere that was the thing in the 60s
but big brother never thought the cam
would be watching that and which was one
of the benefits of that I mean now every
police encounter is on a body camera so
oh that's so polite and watch your head
getting in the police car you know like
idea of beating a suspect now I never
hit the guy you know that doesn't exist
well I'm sure it exists but not to
the extent it used to so it just keeps
everybody honest but it does give you
your news unfiltered and you see people
as they really are which can be pretty
frightening sometimes when you look at
the state of politics in America
particularly fuel perhaps by social
media which tends to inflame the
extremities on both sides do you worry
about that do you worry that America's
becoming ever more polarized politically
being an
optimist my the biggest fear for years
was not enough nobody's voting and
nobody voted this last election whether
you were for Trump or for Biden huge
huge everybody not everybody but the
highest no one ever predicted that they
thought it would just continue to go
down and people under 30 would never
vote and you know well no that all
changed so it it got people interested
so I think that's one of the benefits of
it you know what do you make of the
Donald Trump phenomenon there's there
other way to describe it when in 1999 he
appeared on the tonight's show with you
right uh and was when he first said he
was going to run for president and you
like everybody else laughed at this
concept and you quized him about his
temperament and Trump said this to you I
believe when someone wants to get you
you want to get them and I believe that
and you said but being president you'd
have to be more diplomatic and he
replied yes but I believe in
retribution well a no one's laughing now
because he became president May well be
again and he does exact retribution he's
done exactly what he said he would do
what do you think of this phenomenon of
trump the politician I'm not a fan uh I
think he hasn't likeed this thing but
they want to restrict him on the ballot
I'm against that because that could turn
against you you could use it for
whatever it's anti-democratic right it's
anti-democratic I mean if the people
want that person is President that's
fine I mean I'm not a fan has nothing to
do with politics I I just don't think
morally I I think do a little bit better
all these indictments whatever it might
be you know I just stopped doing
politics in my act altto together
because you know when I did The Tonight
Show the idea was you made fun of both
sides equally and you get those you and
your Republican well miss you and your
Democratic buddies you know and they'd
both be angry and I go oh that's good
you know they both think you're
supporting the other guy now you've got
to take aside and people are angry if
you don't and I find what I would start
to tell a political J they want to know
the punchline before is this Pro or
against you know so I just I just
stopped doing it because I I just want
people to come and laugh and have a good
time that's the idea of doing a comedy
show to me I'm not trying to get my
personal opinion because I think it's
it's useless or worthless to most people
if you ask me I'll tell you but I don't
make it my thing to go out there and
explain to people how I I'm not trying
to influence you you know that's why
Rodney Dangerfield and I were great
friends I knew Rodney for 40 years I
have no idea if he was democrat or
republican we all it was just about the
jokes you know just the economy of words
get to the joke as quickly as possible I
mean to me the classic Rodney joke was I
I'm walking down the street I see a club
that said topless and bottomless I went
in there was nobody there I mean to me
it's I mean it's it's it's so stupid
it's so funny you know and uh but from a
comedic point of view I mean I've known
Trump a long time I did the Celebrity
Apprentice with him I saw him a lot
every night across the border and I saw
actually a different character there
than one I see as a politician but you
know he was always bombastic Larger than
Life always a big exaggerator narcissist
and so on which is fine if you're not
President right yeah I was going to ask
you that when you were interviewing him
as Donald Trump the real estate magnet
come television celebrity what did you
think of him then well I liked him he
was fine he was an interesting character
he was a television character exactly
what you wanted for TV you know somebody
that kind of irritates some people and
amuses other and that's fine I I I I
liked him then I actually did a couple
of jobs for his that I just you know
this January 6 business and all this
other thing that's gets a little much
well I mean I would imagine most
Americans who don't have a kind of
really
visceral horse in the ring in this and
look at it objectively the idea of any
president from either side simply
refusing to accept the result of an
election in America that's a pretty
slippery path yeah yeah that's a very
slippery P it's to me it's like uh I
like my banker to be about finances I
don't want a funny Banker I don't want a
banker who's a flashy dresser with
Italian sports cars and I I like her to
be a banker and that's what I wanted to
present I mean to
me I I see nothing about the economy or
about what's going to be done for the
country it's just getting back at
Hillary or whatever it just seems to be
uh things you shouldn't be worrying
about as president when you look at Joe
Biden he's 10 years older than you yeah
I mean most people including the
majority of Democrats think he's too old
to run again do you think he should
maybe take one for the team and step
aside well well I think means nothing I
mean I'm just curious what you think
well I think he's fine to be president I
think it's harder to run for president
than it is to be you got to go to the
fair and eat the hot dog and you know do
the whole all of that uh
which I mean I don't know I mean it's uh
look I I'm a fan I like the man I've
known him for years I had him on when he
ran in 88 you know so uh to me uh no I
like him I think he's a good guy and you
know the economy is doing pretty good
right I mean that's something Trump said
today he hes the economy tanks I sold
that well I could really do you really
hope that's when I knew we were in
trouble when I would talk I meet people
on the street I'd rather have Putin than
Biden really really you know I mean Army
and Navy used to fight but they would
team up against the Russians or Viet
whoever it might be you know they didn't
continue they wouldn't take the the the
Russian over the army guy over the Navy
guy that's the part I find rather
troubling do you do you worry about what
may happen in this country in terms of
the division if Trump was to get
reelected well you get the government
you deserve I mean that's pretty much
the way the world works or at least the
way America works if that's what people
choose well that's that's what's going
to happen isn't it so I don't know I
would prefer it I mean it seems pretty
calm now the economy seems to be in
pretty good shape I I I sort of like the
things Biden's been doing I think he's
done a really good job with the economy
but you have people now who just if
someone says the economy is terrible it
is okay you
know I mean gas prices has nothing to do
with the president you know all those
type of things so I I don't know I don't
know I I try not to I'm not an expert in
this area this is one thing I love about
America now we're the only place in the
world if you go to Europe we wanted to
talk about the economy so we went to the
University of Economics Department we
got to a truck stop in lar Ohio you know
here in America you go to the truck stop
you talk to the guy and he what he has I
would rather have an expert you know
what does it what does it mean to you to
be an American well it just it it makes
me laugh because it's the only place
like say we don't want I don't want an
experienced politician in the White
House look I don't want a heart surgeon
doing my operation this guy he says he's
studied medicine at home but he said he
can do a better job by God I'm going to
try that guy instead of the I mean
that's that's that's kind of where we
are now I just love when I hear people I
don't want anybody who knows all about
government running the
government well why not why would you
want an expert I if I'm have a broken
transmission I want a transmission guy
I'm not going to get a well I'll take a
look at it I don't know much about it
but by God you know but do you feel
America is still the land of opportunity
you still still got you want to
appreciate America this is why I love
immigrants you know I love people that
come here my new favorite are Nigerians
every Nigerian I meet is smart ambitious
family oriented they really you know I I
I I I Nigerian friend of mine the other
same he said I don't understand about
America why do people come up and hug me
hug me for no reason oh and they give me
a hug and I don't understand but he just
so confused because it just seemed funny
to me but yes I I think it's great I see
Indian am Americans I I see uh by that I
mean folks from India uh very I I mean
these are all you know classic example
we used to do jaywalking we knock on the
door yeah I remember right around here
knocking on the
door guy opens the door he's Spanish but
he speaks English and he's just dressed
kind of like this he in I mean like my
father's here the father comes over in
the house with a a jacket a tie and a
vet
in the house he comes over and he goes
let meet my grandson and the grandson
comes in he's got a t-shirt with an
obscenity on it and he's got a video
game thing in his hand it just made me
laugh because what happens is these
people come here they work hard they eat
pizza hamburgers listen to rock music
they just become Americans they tear it
down and we need another new bunch to
come in and start the whole thing going
again I mean that's what I love about it
I mean I I I think it's great I I love
the The Immigrant experience and that's
not I'm not saying open border I'm not
talking I just talk about the people
that come here want to come here well
America is the ultimate melting it
really do seem to be I don't see people
oh we're trying to get into Moscow we
don't can't I nobody wants to go there
would it been a better country if if the
British Royals had continued to oversee
things oh that would been horrible would
terrible thing that would have
been horrible horrible thing you don't
sometimes think wistfully you could have
been you know Prince Jay and yeah that's
what I want to be Prince J my mother
from Scotland my mother from well I was
going to say I mean the similarity you
have with Donald Trump is you both had
mothers who were Scottish you came out
here and both your fathers were salesmen
in New York right yeah that's true
that's true is that where the parallels
stop I think that's where parall stop I
I again I just don't agree with some of
the moral decisions and other things you
know you think one of one of the secrets
of his success because you can't deny
the success or the popularity
is that he does have well is it success
or popularity I mean what are you
talking about well success in the sense
he won the presidency with zero
experience I mean that's pretty
extraordinary right uh in popularity he
got 10 million votes more last election
than the first time around which is
pretty staggering given how divisive his
tenure was and he may well win again the
poll suggest he's got a very good chance
is one of the secrets of this popularity
that Trump has with a with a a volume of
the population here that he does have a
comedic streak he makes people laugh
yeah yeah well you know and to me I
think you have to have the ability
to I don't dislike people who like Trump
I mean I meet people all the time you
know guys that are uh mechanics or like
bluecollar guys that like Trump for that
reason and I like them I like them I
don't you know we live in an era now if
you have an electric car you're a vegan
and you voted for Biden and you want
Governor Nome to be president of the
United States if you have a gas car you
like guns you like you know the idea
that you you you've got to be one or the
other to me I I have I like to have
friends on both sides it's like when I
used to watch the news I I used to get
news I didn't know about or wasn't
interested in but I got it because it
was part of the news now when we watch
news we watch MSNBC or we watch Fox or
we we just watch the news we want to see
and I find that really annoying I I like
learning something I didn't know or
hearing other points of view I mean I
talk to I have friends that are huge
Trump supporters and we tease each other
I don't dislike them I just disagree
with them the idea that you can't
disagree with someone without hating
them it seems just horrible to me just I
don't get that I is that one of the
reasons that there's a a sense that far
less is being actually done done in the
senate in Congress because it's so
visceral now the tribalism on both sides
I think very difficult for politicians
to do deals with the other side I think
so and if and if you do you're a traitor
or whatever it might be you know I I
mean you know I like Mitt Romney I think
he's a terrific guy um great human being
uh the fact that he gets
ostracized from the Republican party
because of his views is nuts
but I I think he's I think he's correct
I I mean I I don't want a president
who's been uh impeached two times it
just
seems I think we can do better do you
think anyone should be allowed to run
for presid on on any side if you're
facing a 100 criminal charges well you
can the Constitution says you can you
think that's right well what I think
doesn't matter like an
American well I have the right not to
vote for them right so I would I would
here's my vote if you choose to have
someone who's a criminal as president
okay I have to accept your choice I I
that's what that's what a democracy is I
get that so the idea you think you
should be allowed to stop that no if if
he's able to bamboozle you or fool you
or whatever you want to call it uh well
that's that's the way it goes what do
you make of the the woke culture
particularly where it pertains to cancel
culture this kind of weird new liberal
fueled fascism which of course is the
antithesis of what they profess to stand
for but what what do you think of it
well you know to
me I always meet comedians that say uh
you know you can't even compliment women
anymore well yeah you can't go hey nice
boobs okay if you were to say oh that's
a really pretty dress I don't any
remember go
actually there are some that would now
take no but see but I think objectify
what I'm saying is I said oh that's a
nice outfit oh thank you I mean I'm I'm
using normal people common sense not one
extreme or the other most people know
when you've crossed the line you know I
mean it's just I I just people think
that this isn't be going well JG hugging
a woman you've never met and just
hugging a little too hard you know I
mean you you have an inner sense of
what's a me what's what's inappropriate
did did the me too campaign go too far
is the pendulum coming back well no I
think any any pendulum swings to the far
left to the far right before it comes
back to center it's just something that
happens I
mean yeah no I I I think it is what it
is and I think you're seeing it come
back to center now okay I think there's
a lot of anger a lot of animosity uh
women over the years have built up
um you know if if you were someone this
happened to you in the 60s 7s and 80s
you're going to be pretty mad in the 90s
and the 2000s so I I get it I I
understand it and is it unfair that it
swings that way yeah but it's unfair it
went the other way too so you
interviewed a lot of people who were
mewed mhm were was that a surprise to
you when you found out what some of them
were actually
like well for a lot of them you kind of
knew they were like that I mean there's
not a lot of people where I go oh really
I'm surprised that you
know it's Harvey Weinstein I
mean he was always a bully he was a
bully he would call me and say I I I
need so and so on the show tomorrow
night and I go I can't I got so well get
kick them off I go hurry I'm not going
to do and he would yell at me and
intimidate well you're not going to get
any you know he would just be that way
all the and he was a bully so when when
he got caught I was not the least bit
surprised uh but what was your question
again well just whether you felt I mean
were any for example that you know where
you felt they were dealt a rough
card yeah I do know some that was it
rough did they still do the deed yes all
right so you know you really have to be
on the other side to understand it's one
of those issues I mean people used to
say things like I remember some
Senator a little before the me too movie
there someone had been raped and well
you should just sit back and enjoy it if
it's inevitable it's going to happen you
that was Ho Ho that was like a guy joke
and it was a guy joke but it wasn't a
joke to women you know I mean it was not
that long ago racial jokes were
something did on TV or or on the radio
especially radio shows did black joke oh
my I know black guy he doesn't mind
you're not black you you don't have the
right to say that and I think the same
thing with women too as well I mean
women drivers used to be a common theme
for comedians blondes all that kind of
stuff uh and it takes something like
this to get people not to when you talk
to men under the age of 30 now they
really understand very different it's
very different and my sons ruled in
their 20s they they think very
differently about it and it's all for
the better isn't it isn't it better yeah
I mean so I well it's better to the
point I would say where it gets taken
too far and any kind of humor what I
would frame the office banter style
humor right taking as we were saying
them taking the Mickey out of each other
sending each other up that's almost
become a criminal offense just across
the board where no one dares make any
jokes about anything or anyone for fear
of somebody being offended I'm a
comedian I don't really have that
problem I've had it a little bit once in
a while so you know what I do I
apologize you know something my point
was to make you laugh a lot of times the
point is not to make you laugh you had a
story where you're in a Chinese
restaurant with your wife and the
waitress took offense tell me we we were
at a little Chinese restaurant and um it
wasn't a waitress H it like the mom ran
the cash register and she was about 55
the dad was in the kid the kids were so
it's like a family place you know and
it's may be 14 tables mostly college
students and my wife on eating and the
woman is just taking the orders I said I
said man This Woman's really working her
ass off you know and a female college
student said uh she's a
server I said
well I said you know look I I'm not
arguing with you I I said I try to watch
what I say and I thought woman was
appropriate I said if I had said given
she's actually a woman yeah know but if
I had said that server you said have
said woman I said I said I said to her
you know I didn't say waitress I didn't
say chick I didn't say stewardess I said
that woman is really working her ass off
you think you'd be offended at the ass
part but no uh it's the woman part well
yeah she said which is insane and said
well you know some I didn't get I just
and the woman apolog the girl she goes
well I guess I go you understand what
I'm saying I mean I looked on I said
Okay She's a woman and I thought from in
okay well This Woman's really working
her ass off because she's you know all
the tables and taking the A and
and and this person said I said it's s
pop and it really was no pop but when
you see for example uh the issue around
women's sport and trans athletes where
you see you know very tall powerful B
former biological or the biological
males who identified as men and now
identify as women and start to crush
women in in their sporting
arenas that seems to me just insane well
I I I can't disagree with you there I I
understand understand it I don't know
enough about it I mean I know I have
friends of mine whose daughters were
Olympic hopefuls and came in second or
third when they would have been first if
it had been biologically but I you know
I don't know I I don't know it's just
unfair isn't it well it seems on the
surface unfair to me I don't I don't
study the issue enough and this is the
thing with a lot of people too they just
give their opinion without knowing all
the facts so I don't know all the facts
on that but on the surface I would say
well I mean couldn't you have three
categories that you know but I don't
know I don't know that's a tricky one I
appeared on the tonight's show several
times when you were the host absolutely
loved it and what struck me about the
whole kind of Mythology around you The
Tonight Show Your Rivals and so on was a
narrative began to build that you were
some kind of Ruthless monster when my
personal experience of you we didn't
know each other certainly the first time
was you couldn't have been more friendly
graci ious normal non- monstrous in fact
you were the complete opposite one of
the nicest people genuinely I'd met in
the business what did you feel when that
became this sort of thing about you that
people were saying this stuff well like
I always
say if you're playing football who do
you tackle you tackle a guy with the
ball it's as simple as that you know my
attitude is I don't believe the good
stuff and I don't believe the bad stuff
like know well thank on right kind guys
I didn't like your monolog oh okay well
I'm sorry nice see are you very funny oh
thank you I'm not that funny but okay
thank you you know so I mean to me
that's sort of where I am um I mean
that's what kind of happens in The
Tonight Show when you look back on that
whole period particularly when it all
went sour for almost everybody involved
right so you know lean Conan you and
everything when you look back on it it
was clearly a febal kind of period do
you have any regrets about it yourself
no I loved it it was great I'm sorry you
know you're in a high paid job please
you know there people have really tough
jobs where you're dealing with criminals
or a policeman or a nurse of people are
bleeding all right you're just dealing
with bruised Eagles most of the time and
that's fine no I don't I I don't regret
any of it I was fine no it was fine I
enjoyed it I loved it I mean actually
the favorite part of my career is when I
was doing Letterman in the 80s cuz I
would put together like I would go on
once a month and have a six or eight
minute piece and try it out on Dave and
see that was the first time in my life
cuz I grew up in the East and when I
came out I do I go thank you Mr Carson
it's Johnny well I didn't grow up to
call like I love it when they come in go
Jay this is my parents Bob and Agnes
well how are you Mrs Mrs mitelli nice
nice I can't I can't I said I can't call
your mom Bob and Agnes I I just feel
ridic even though they're like almost
the same ages me I just feel ridiculous
you know it's just the way I was so when
I got on the letter the first time AG
goe Dave ni tie Dave you know I could
make I could eat a sandwich in front of
that was my favorite thing to do because
let him he would always get kind of the
Jitters before he went on you know but
you were great friends then oh yeah you
know and still please are you still
friends yes we never I mean in what in
what sense I mean do you do you ring
each other do you see each other no but
I have a lot when you you know when
you're a comedian when was the last time
you spoke to him oh a long time ago like
like what yes but I could I could pick
up the conversation tomorrow a year 10
years a couple years couple years couple
years yeah but you know like Billy
Christen I we hardly we never had dinner
I never been to his house I love the guy
I think he loves me I just did his thing
at the Kennedy because he was a he's
another com you know when you start out
you don't know anybody that's a comedian
and you know growing up in Massachusetts
I would always hear my mom's you know
Kathy's boy wants to be comedian oh
that's so he'll get he'll grow out of
that I hope he does you know he that's
those kind of com said you were the
funniest of them all well that was very
kind of he also said you were very
insecure I don't think I'm insecure but
that that's okay what did you feel when
he said that well I like the funniest I
like the insec so somewhere in the
middle so I get a c i get a c so that's
okay what do you what do you think of
him professionally I love you know
something when we started here's we sort
of met at the comedy store
Dave was sort of a nervous performer but
great word Smith I mean you could weave
words together in exactly the
phraseology where the joke was in the
phraseology as opposed to the punchline
you know uh I was kind of loud and
verbose and do different voices and
things like that and David go well how
can you be so loose on stage I said man
I love the way you weave sentences
together and I think we sort of
complimented each other L mcconney huh
well yeah maybe maybe um and and so when
I would go on Dave a lot of times the
joke would be on the way to the joke I
Dave and I S the old Manson place are
the Manson Place J know Tex and all the
guys and let would start to laugh and we
would just sort of roll on that and
actually sometimes never even get to
what the joke was and that's what was
fun just that natural flow because I
think we we comp compliment each other I
mean to making Dave
laugh was my greatest thing I remember
once letter was on the cover of Success
magazine and so I went I said Dave we
Sorry in the cover and he goes I put
that down no Dave did you see him here
on the cover of success and I say you
know Dave I'm on a magazine and then I
pick up a a bigger version called super
Success magazine and my face is out and
then he realized oh because he didn't he
didn't know where the joke was going to
go he was just awkward being
complimented you know and and and so it
really was the comp a slam and then he
thought that was funny and to me that
was that was was the the greatest time
in my life cuz it was just comedy just
going on trying to make each other laugh
and having a good time would you love to
just like have a long lunch or dinner
with him and sort of I would enjoy that
I mean I don't know I think it'd be fun
and it'd be fun to do the to do what we
used to do just Arnold Schwarz snigger
and slice delone they they hang out
together having been tremendous Rivals
they now hang out together most weeks if
they're in town they get a cafe RoR and
they just chew the fat together right
and they get a lot out of that it's
almost like after the war right well I'm
sort of like the way with Seinfeld when
Seinfeld and I get together and talk we
each Come Away with something some piece
of material some little nugget of
something that we can use you know uh
because he is one of the great comics
and to to me he likes the technical
aspect of writing jokes you know and let
was the same way too very clever very
sharp you know uh good ad Liber no I I I
I'm
hugely a fan of Dave you know I was real
happy because I would get the ratings
and he would get the critics and that
was fine with me or I could have
switched that at any point I'll take
critics or well you take R all right
fine I mean it it it it it didn't matter
I like the fact we both were successful
and we both came away with with uh with
something what about Cen ibrian I like
Conan I you know that that's another one
of those weird
situations that when he was at NBC
Don omire was not a fan and he said I
like this guy to third you know he asked
me what I thought I said I like him I
think he's really funny I said I tell
you what I'll promote him every night at
the end of my show hey stay tun for con
and he's got uh you know Sean Conor
whatever it might be and so we did that
every night and that was fine and then
uh after quite a few years um Jeff
Zucker came to me and said uh K's people
want you out he wants the show I go what
are we do well here here's my favorite
thing I said well I'm number one and I
remember one of the NBC Executives said
you know we want what's above number
one I said that is so la yeah and I said
well what what is that well we just want
I said be better than number one Jay and
to me I always sign pay and play
contracts I never sign you know I say
people I got a development deal they
have to pay me even if I don't work and
I go okay you don't want that because if
they're paying you not to work that
means they don't want you to work
they're paying you not to work so my
deals are always if you paying me you
got to so my contract was pretty I'm on
for five years said okay at the end of
five years they want to replace you with
Conan and I said I didn't have a manager
I didn't have an agent I didn't have any
really did it with yourself no I do it
myself I said look if they don't want
you I don't want to die of a thousand
paper cuts you know what I'm saying so I
said okay fine so I'll Tire after next
five years Conan's doing fine and then
Craig Ferguson comes along who is great
and Craig Ferguson goes out the con and
then suddenly he starts winning he wins
a py award and other things and every
nominee and they go and then suddenly
Jeff looker and everybody's like oh did
we make a mistake I said guys I'm here
I'm what am I doing I said well
uh been trying to figure out what to do
they said you want to you want to stay
on I go what am I going to stay us so
they we'll do a 10:00 show I never
thought a 10:00 show would work but they
said I tell we'll pay your staff for two
years full benefits pay all right we'll
try it well it lasted about nine months
because we're competing with Law and
Order and 10:00 drama series and stuff
it didn't work uh and then they said
well how if you go on at 11:30 for half
an hour and K takes it from 12 I said if
K will go for that I'll go for it but
well they brought that to he said no and
he quit so then they came to me he said
I want you to come back I said all right
fine but there was no isn't the truth
really I mean I read it all and isn't
the truth in the end you didn't want to
leave the tonight's show in the first
place you were number one I didn't want
to leave you didn't want to leave you
were put in a position where you kind of
were forced to and everything else
unraveled from that you've still been
blamed by certain number of people about
it all but it seemed to me that your
only crime was that you were number one
in a show you love doing right right
yeah and you didn't want to give it up
yeah that's pretty much it I mean that
was the story wasn't it that was the
story yeah but I mean the idea that I
would read these things that L demanded
$150 million no I said how they fired me
how could I demand you know they have
all these ridiculous things and isn't it
true that you you never used any of your
money from television no
nothing I'm a comedian I make my living
doing standup comedy if you get a TV
show oh that's nice but TV shows last
either either 6 weeks or 22 years what
did you do with these hundreds of
millions of
dollars still there untouched well I
mean not untouched but yeah yeah I I
live pretty with the exception of cars
and motorcycles I about to say you live
frugally surrounded by the greatest in
history I'm still using the happy me
coupons you know I mean it's funny
because I'm one of those people I live
on what I I make that week if I don't
work this week I think I'm brok is that
is that going back to the early days of
Comedy oh yeah yeah all comedians seem
to have that streak in them they're
terrified that one day they'll be back
there you always you have to be hungry
are you still as hungry as ever yes
really yes that's amazing yes I all your
success everything you've achieved yeah
you still have that burning inside you
well I I mean I like to write jokes and
tell them you like to try them out I
mean so the same joke you do over here
at Flappers of the comedy magic club uh
you same when you get paid tons of money
in Vegas do you think you could still be
doing The Tonight Show I mean if if
everything had just been left as it was
well I think at some point you realize I
shouldn't have to know all of jayc's
music you know I mean I knew I was it
was going to while to go Ladi and G my
next guest is so more albums than Elvis
and The Beatles combined please welcome
who is this who is this guy I never
heard of the song I don't know him I'm
meeting him for the first time what I
mean then I realized okay maybe it's
getting a little you know I had two
moments on The Tonight Show with you
which I I will never forget
one you know about because you said it
to me the other one you don't know about
I think but the first one was when I was
at CNN and I was taking on the NRA about
the the gun the mass shootings after
Sandy Hook and it was getting very
unpleasant the whole debate and you came
and saw me in my dressing room for a cup
of tea and you said look here's the deal
Pi the problem is he said that you're
preaching to an audience most of whom
probably have guns or light guns it's a
bit like if you went to Germany and told
them to stop speeding on the autoban
right they don't want to hear it from
you and they definitely don't want to
hear it from your accent and I thought
it was a brilliant advice it really made
me stop and think that actually it's a
it's American culture and for somebody
from Britain to come in and start
lecturing Americans about right their
culture there are clear issues with the
gun violence in this country which need
to be soled but Amer an need to sort
that themselves right it can't be down
to you know somebody like Mad King
Charles's making got me like something
about making Georgia success right right
yeah well I remember you doing that and
I was very grateful because it put it
into clear senseful um and the other
thing you probably don't know I did the
show Once with Robin Williams we were
the only two guests and I was in my
dressing room and it was just when Susan
Bole had become the biggest breakout
reality talent show star in history with
I dreamed a dream and I was under the
dressing with my late great manager John
and we were sitting there and the door
knocked and in came Robin Williams but
he was in character he was half Susan
Bole half Mrs Doubtfire funny and he did
a 15minute turn just impromptu it was
one of the funniest things I've ever
watched in my life and it was just for
me and my manager and then he went and
that was it and we were on stage we did
our bit with you that was it and we went
our separate ways I never saw him again
but it was an introduction to Real
Genius oh yeah he was Rob Williams he's
fabulous you know I first met him he was
posing as a Russian comedian and I was
telling people this kid he's funny but
he speaks Russian he's not really you
know I I didn't realize it was Rob yeah
so yeah no you know a Real Genius yeah
really incredibly sad what happened to
him did you see that sad did you did you
see that side to him that he well well I
always he was always well Robin was
always on whether it's the comedy clubs
or wherever
um did I think that what would happen
happen that he would take his own no I I
didn't see that coming at all I I'm not
going to pretend that I did a lot of
Comedians and maybe it's because they're
constantly trying to make people laugh
and live or die by that professionally
seem to suffer from well first of all
it's a genetic flaw it's not a PL I mean
we just happen to live in a time when it
pays huge dividends I mean if this is
the Crusades who's making the soldiers
laugh that guy kill him get that guy out
of here just kill him me making the
soldiers laugh taking their mind just
kill that guy you know so that that's
where we are now it pays dividends but
yeah the idea of want you get out and
perform in front of people is just sort
of that's a little odd is it you know so
yeah when you see people like Dave
Chappelle literally being attacked on
stage for their comedy does that worry
you that that that line has been crossed
now where people you when you saw what
happened with Will Smith well it makes
me laugh because I used to work strip
clubs I I once worked a plays in Atlanta
well there were two one's called the
mine
shaft and it was a strip club and they
this is before Comedy Club they had
comedias and you bought a ticket and
then for $10 you got a A miners hat with
a light on it okay so that was there
were no lights in the club that was the
light of the lights so girls would be on
stage because the lights are always
right so you never even saw the girl's
face and as a comedian I just be
standing in the dark and it just be like
aund Harley coming at you at all times
you know that kind of thing then I
worked at a place called the Rodeo
Lounge that had chicken wire so it' be
on stage telling jokes boom a bottle
would just bounce off the outside of it
and smash on the ground so people throw
so the idea that you quite used to all
this no the idea of being attacked on
stage oh that's fine yeah compared to
people throwing bottles and was actually
okay you know do you worry about where
comedy's going do you no I don't worry
about you know comedy's not going
anywhere it's the exact same thing it's
always been you know if I ask you to
watch a Rudolph Valentino movie from the
20s I think you'd be bored to death or
you'd laugh you know this kind of
gesture it wouldn't seem sexy romantic
would you but if I showed you a Charlie
Chaplain or bust Keaton I think you
would laugh as hard maybe harder because
of the funny clothes and the cars and
the speed up film than people did back
then because comedy is comedy now I
don't think it changes that much when
you saw Will Smith slap Chris Rock at
the Oscars what went through your mind
watching
that well what went through my mind is
somebody totally misreading a
situation how many times have you heard
about for example I remember there was a
famous case of police officer who set
something up on a bus to look like a
girl's being being attacked and he would
be the hero uh you know like and I think
you're sitting there and someone's
insulting your wife and go bet if I go
up and I SM I bet people go yeah look
you know John wils Booth the exact same
thing John wils Booth the actor who shot
Abraham Lincoln hugely popular and hated
Lincoln and the South hated Lincoln he
go well I'm going to get up there I'm
going to kill Lincoln and I will be a
bigger star than and that's that that
was his motivation that he they would
make him more famous and more powerful
well that backfired pretty quick but are
you comparing Will Smith to the worst
the most notorious assassin in American
history not that but it's just the idea
that you know you've got this thing
going okay guy in s I'm going up there
I'm going to I'm going to slap him for
CU it's not I don't think it's
far-fetched to think that some people
would see that as hey that's a real man
or women go I wish my husband would do
that when that guy in a bar insulted me
you know so that's what I like to think
probably went through his mind he just
misread the
situation uh but who knows who knows
does that make sense to you it does it
does I mean it was interesting to me a
lot of people did support Will Smith a
lot of people didn't I mean it was quite
split actually and the polls were kind
of 50/50 it was interesting well I think
you also have a situation as that being
African-American you know my dad was
Italian I'm half Italian my mother some
Scotland but my dad was Italian so every
time an Italian did something
bad again with the Italian like you know
when Le Coke was on the cover of Time
Magazine oh that went up on the wall as
an Italian the son as an Italian you can
be pride of look at a business man you
here you know so I I think two
African-American guys fighting on the
stage I I mean I was I would tease Kevin
Eubanks all time when I was doing the
ton show of a black guy got Kev the
black guy Jay no that's that's not a
black thing Jay that's just a white oh
it's not a white you know I mean we we
just sort of take the Mickey as you say
out each you know so I I I think there's
a lot of reasons why you don't drink you
don't smoke you don't take drugs are
cars your only Vice well I I'm I'm
stunned that people have fall into the
cliches of all the time you know I me I
gave a commencement address at a college
and I talked about that people in ch
rarely does their failure have anything
to do with their talent they're too
straight they're too gay they're too
high they're too drunk they're too
jealous they're too prideful they're too
Envy there's some other reason RAR is it
your jokes are not funny or you're a bad
actor it's usually some other thing some
sexual things so I'm just amazed that
people that just fall into that trap
continuously but they would counter by
saying it's probably more amazing that
you've managed to avoid these P I am a
huge believer in low
self-esteem low self-esteem is the key
to suc a lack of ego well no but you
don't think you know you can have an ego
but if you don't think you're the
smartest person in the room you know I I
always meet friends that get television
shows and then they wind up the staff
hates them
because I I think most most people can't
do anything some people can do one thing
other people can do two maybe three but
other than that so to me when I got The
Tonight Show I said can we just hire the
best line who's the best line director
let's get him let's get the best
director and then I listened to them
when they said you look bad under that
light they didn't argue I go okay thanks
you know I always told my staff anybody
can pull the card and stopped the train
okay just let me know if if we did a
skit so you know I mean the catering guy
go J that joke really was not funny was
it no then I say was it funny yeah it
was funny no actually it wasn't well
don't tell me the catering guy to people
could tell me it's funny cuz I watched
the Golden Globes other other night were
you watching it no I didn't watch it but
I heard about it so Joe who I'd never
heard of but he was this standup guy
very nice guy very funny guy right
incredibly unfunny presenting the Golden
Globes I mean it was like cring making
to watch well that's a tough crowd
that's but you can still tell funny
jokes well not when you have just a few
days to prepare I mean he took the job
the last minute if I was an agent if I
gave you 10 minutes notice to do the
Globes I wouldn't do it you still make
people laugh you could Wing your way
through it no no because that's a
totally that is a crowd you know you
can't have you done any of those award
shows no I always I always I got asked
to host Oscars a couple times I said
look I say look I tell jokes every night
on The Tonight Show do I save my best
jokes for The Tonight Show or do I do my
best jokes on the Oscars but during the
nobody wants to see me do jokes five
nights a week or and then the sixth
night oh I come out and I tell jokes
again you just saw me Friday night you
saw me Thursday you saw me Wednesday you
saw me Tuesday no it's the same reason I
never did commercials when I was on T
I'm on TV every day I don't need to be
on TV in between when I'm on TV you know
what I mean a little bit goes a long way
so you're sympathy of a joeoy yes I do
because I know he's funny and it's just
not well I can remember one big star I
had well I it was Walken Phoenix he he
was on the show and he was in character
when he had the beard and just sort of
mumbling about character at the end of
the show I said uh hey thanks for coming
here next time I hope you can come in
person you know so his public say he is
a genius you don't talk to him that I go
he wasn't a genius T he was kind of rude
and really wasn't that funny you know
and he it wasn't that interesting you
know I mean I guess he's a nice guy but
he was just being very you know if you
don't want to be there fine don't don't
be there you know but yeah that's sort
of I mean I'll tell you a funny story
lat Charlie Sheen I I love Charlie I
love Charlie Charlie Sheen you know that
was a great thing about doing The
Tonight Show I could be in Show Business
without being in Show Business you know
I love observing Charlie Sheen I don't
want to be Charlie so one day we got
Charlie on the show and I'm sitting at
the desk at rehearsal Jay phone it's
Charlie Chen Jay Jay it's Charlie man
listen the the limo got T-boned on the
101 uh caught fire you okay I'm okay man
look go home okay we rescheduled okay
yeah okay okay
thank Charlie don't worry we'll get some
we'll get a comment get somebody don't
worry about hey Charlie she got in an
accient you know I said turn on the news
you know I got TMZ is anything about
Charlie so I said to the uh I said to
Transportation hey who's picking up is
it Joe give me Joe's number Joe hey it's
jayen hey where are you I'm in front of
Charlie's house he hasn't come out yet
what do you mean he hasn't come out yet
did you get T-boned what no I'm I called
joh go what are you like eight years old
as's a Monster Under the Bed did you
really think you would fool me I mean it
just it just made what do they say when
you out it just it just made me laugh it
just that show business I I'll say they
was say just say I have a cold or I'm
high or I'm drunk I I'm not I don't feel
well enough to do just it just made me
laugh that it was a T-bone and it was an
accient yeah he gave me the first
interview after he quit Two and a Half
Men and he was winning yeah exactly he
got the tiger blood all and he just just
come out of it and I got the first
interview he turned up 30 seconds before
we were du to do it live at CNN here in
LA and he came on and he was brilliant
amazing interview and he brandished
proudly his drugs report which was
negative and he showed me look it's
negative netive I'm clean great that's
great brilliant and then in the next
commercial break I saw him sign it and
he handed it to me just before we went
back on air and he just said two peers
on the drugs test report two peers let's
get hammered after the show
Charlie I was laughing so much I could
barely do this second it just made just
made me laugh just made me laugh who
were the who are your favorite guests
when you look back at it Rodney was a
favorite one I'll tell you Rodney story
you know I used to love Rodney dangi
Rodney Dangerfield when Rodney was on
with Johnny I love watching Johnny the
straight man been a rough time Ry oh
Johnny I tell you it's a rough you know
they do the Jo it's cold pretty cold was
oh was so cold whatever it might be so I
said oh I would love to be able to do
that so when I got The Tonight Show
doing out with Rodney so I think in 2001
I had Rodney on the show and he was in
his
80s and he came out he's a little off
his game not much just you know like
instead he' go like this instead his
hand would go here you know little
things as a comic I noticed maybe the
general public so while he's doing his
act I I said to Debbie our producer I
said I think Rodney's having a stroke
you call paramedic she goes really I go
no I think he is okay so anyway but
being the confidence professional he he
finished sits down things good I'm okay
J but last week I tell you you know he
goes into and he was fine then the show
ends rodne is his dressing room by this
time the paramedics came in and I I go
Rodney can the paramedics t look at I
think maybe had a stroke he goes I'm
okay I'm okay well he did have a stroke
really and they took him out in the
stretcher and he passed away not long
after that wow but his wife Joan called
me and she said J Rodney's here at the
hospital he's in a coma can you come I
said okay so I go down and r his line of
his light eyes open you know and Jan
says the doctor says he can hear
everything we're
saying so I'm telling how much we loved
him and how great he was to us young
Comics we were starting out to let us
work at Dangerfield's club and I used to
sleep in the store room behind the club
you know and he just telling these
stories so then Joan says Jay Jay she
goes
Rodney she goes Jay put your finger in
Rodney's hand she goes Rodney if you
know it's Jay try and squeeze his finger
so I put my mying and I feel like a
slight squeeze and I went Rodney that's
not my
finger so Rodney so Rodney shoulder goes
like this he moved he moved he moved he
moved you know and then the nurse comes
in what's going on he moved and and he
he passed away not long after that
amazing but just to get that final out
of Rodney was was one and another great
guest was um I love Shan connory yeah
because he was not James Bond you know
he people don't realize he was miss the
universe third runner up 1953 and he was
a long showman he was a tough guy do you
he the story of him and uh Johnny
stampado you know that's no that's
Johnny stampado was a gangster who was
dating Lana Turner I mean a real
Gangster and apparently Lana
Turner was flirting with uh Sean Cony on
this twickingham studio so Johnny stomal
flies over to England confronts Sean
conary on the set puts a gun to his head
joh takes a gun smashes s on the head
with aun you don't bring a gun to my
workplace I take some bullets out yeah
just just that kind just that kind of
guy so I love having whenever Sean Cony
come to the show he go g g what's the
latest filthy joke going about you you
know so I would tell him the joke and he
would laugh like a
pirate he would laugh like he would
literally slap his knee go my God funny
and he was the only one who would take a
shower in those little dressing rooms
and he would sing Oh to Scotland he just
sing Scottish songs you know and the
news crew could out what trying to do
the news I said Sean Conor sh in the
shower so he just all he was the only
star I ever heard my mother go you
that's a real man jimie I go M I don't
want you to talk like no jimie that's a
real man that Sean com you also had the
six most famous words probably in talk
show history when you looked at Hugh
Grant
after his little indiscretion in Los
Angeles with oh what were you thinking
certain what the hell were you
thinking yeah that was just an ad lib it
did you think about that before or did
just come out no I just asked him and
you know he was great because in those
days I'm sure he had a publicist but he
came by himself I went in the dressing
room I said look I got to ask you about
this you can answer I'm not going to
contradict you or or belabor the point
but I just have to answer she goes
that's okay I deserve it you know he he
was very funny and he was very nice you
know nowadays everybody has crisis
management teams and all that kind of
nonsense but no he he was really
terrific but I'll tell you one that was
really interesting to
me uh I
was 13 when John F Kennedy was
assassinated I remember coming home from
school and my mother's watching the TV
and tears are streamed out she's
watching the
funeral and when they pass apart where
little John J you salute in the casket
oh my mother just um you know when your
mom send hysterics and your kid what I I
what to do you know my mom's just oh
that little boy what going to happen you
know and she's just so upset by this and
okay fine go ahead 40 something years I
have John F Kenny Jr on this had
Seinfeld as first guest and John I'm in
the dressing room it didn't strike me
hey John hey thanks for coming on
congratulations good luck with the
magazine it's really good magazine we
talk a little bit you know okay my next
guest is the president please welcome
jonath K as he comes around the curtain
I shake his hand I look up the
Monitor and I didn't start to cry but I
almost said because I never thought that
Circle of my mom JFK that those three
but I I actually saw my mom in the
monitor well you know what I mean I just
I just flashed it took you back to that
moment yeah because she had seen it on
TV and it didn't I didn't think of my
mom when it's was in the dressing room
it wasn't until until I looked at the TV
and I as my mom was watching him on the
TV and I'm watching him on the TV and I
mean even Debbie said to me what
happened during the intro there I said
oh nothing I just uh got a little choked
up over what I said well I think I told
her afterwards but that's amazing took
you took you back to that well yeah just
took me right back to that and it was
like a just an interesting moment yeah
you lost both your parents within the
space of a year I think they di very
soon after each other I mean that's a a
massive blow I guess slightly mitigated
by the fact they were
reunited so quickly but what what do you
feel you owe your
parents oh my parents are wonderful
hilarious my mother to the day she died
never understood I remember my mother
telling my aunt nety what I did for
Living Well Jay has a little skit that
he puts on from town to
town you know like I do a little
dance it just always made me laugh you
know in fact that you when I started it
was The Tonight Show starring Jay Leno
and my mother or starting jilen listen
to him now is Mr fancy Mr starting I go
M that's TV oh starting J like they
don't know you there already you got to
put your name star in like my mother
wouldn't let this try she just thought
that oh it was so eego Mania so I I
changed the Tonight Show with Jay and we
just really because of that oh yes
brilliant because my mother starting Jay
I remember I called my mom and said he M
I'm on the cover of Time Magazine oh
which one time mag magine you know time
oh yeah I know that yeah Time Magazine M
oh that's good you're on the cover okay
I'll pick that up I said wellist call
Uncle Frank in Florida call anun Fay in
New Jersey and you know and so and so on
can I get tell her mother po she goes
well I mean I think they put you on the
cover the ones they sell around here
because they know you're from this area
she goes I don't think you're on the I
go M I'm on the cover everywhere she
goes I don't think so I got no M I'm on
the cover everywhere I mean my mother
could never get over helping and when
they would get recognized you
know my mother go to oh Leno are you oh
did you go to school with my son how no
no on TV MA that's that's all yeah yeah
it just yeah no they what was your dad
like my my dad was the same thing the
same thing they you know do you get your
humor from them do you think yeah they
were pretty funny you know my dad was an
insurance salesman my dad was a priz
fighter and he sold insurance and they
made him manager and once a month mon my
dad would put on a show to ins Inspire
them it was all men selling Insurance in
those days it was door to door so he
would say you guys you guys can't sance
I can't juggle by the end of the month
I'm going to know how to juggle you know
so he would practice it the end of the
month you throw eggs and eggs would hit
him in the face and they would laugh you
know you know and he would just do
things like that but my dad was a great
role model you know my dad he was a
prize fighter and he told me to quit
prize fighting because he realized even
on his best stay at work you got punch
in the face and he realized it's not a
good job so he started selling insurance
and he went into his boss he said what's
the hardest what's your hardest district
and they said Harlem and my dad said why
black people don't buy insurance why
would they buy insurance they have
families no I don't care about that you
know just so my D well that can't be
true so my dad said well give me har so
my dad started selling nickel policies
in Harlem and he made it a pretty
successful area and he he he kind of
turned it around and when he died I
talked about on Tonight Show I got a
letter from a lady who I guess at this
time was in her 80s and 90s and she said
when she was a little girl was a Mr
Angelo used to come to her house uh to
collect the nickel policy and always had
a tootsie roll or a lollipop for her and
he was the first white man ever to have
dinner in their apartment and she said
when she grew up she
hoped she'd meet a lot of Italian people
and hope they would be nice like Mr
Angelo wow and that's when my you you
realize one person can really make a
difference you know it just not my dad
wasn't a civil rights and all but he
just believed every but he sold he was
in this area and he got to know his his
people and and and and he would collect
anal policy and he have dinner once or
twice a week in one of the houses there
and just the fact this lady said that
that's what I mean when my dad was proud
when Italians would be on the because
you know with the go made you quite
emotional yeah I I do get emotional
about that because it it really it
really struck me that my dad was not a
well educated guy he was smart but he
knew the difference between right and
wrong and you
know that's was it's very moving to see
how yeah it was really really something
for me because that was a leading by
example yes you know that's what my dad
always did it wasn't that wasn't just
cuz I drink and smoke doesn't mean you
can drink it yeah it wasn't that that's
what you heard from most have we lost
that kind of oldfashioned no you want
that you want that go to immigrants talk
to Nigerians talk to people from India
talk to people from any other country
most of them tend to bring those values
here and I I think that's pretty
good we're in a garage full of
spectacular wonderful cars a lot of them
are wonderful cars a lot of just cars I
like so but the point I was going to
make was that you were in here I think a
year or so ago when you had a horrific
accident oh yeah yeah yeah uh I mean
really horrific and it could have been
even worse tell me what happened where
were you first of all oh I was in the I
was in the shop and I got a face full of
gas and a what was the car you were
working uh 1907 White Steam car and my
face car were you underneath it or I was
underneath the gas hit me in the face
and then a spark jumped yeah and you and
you were literally on fire oh yeah I was
on fire and I said Dave I'm on fire he
said what and he pulled me out and
jumped on top he's one of the guys that
works in your life yeah well he he
doesn't work here but he's a friend of
my so okay so then uh I drove to the
hospital and uh I got to the hospital
and they said okay we'll check you and I
go well I gotta go home and get my wife
first I said oh no you can't go home me
I said no I'll go look guys I'll come
back in the morning so so I go home and
I could go to sleep how did you get home
you drove I drove yeah you drove
yourself I drove myself but I went to
bed may your face has been on fire yeah
my face on fire then I went to bed then
I woke up the pillow had melted to my
face my God so I'm sitting there with
scissors
cutting the pillow oh my God so I would
back to the hospital they took the
pillow off my face and and then you know
it was a what did your wife say when you
came back well that's what I mean I
didn't want I didn't want her to think
because she wasn't driving anymore at
that point she had no way to get to me
and I didn't want uh her to be worried
so so I went home and you know and I put
some water on I think well this will be
fine this you know this will be fine you
know you in a lot of pain I I I guess so
I yeah I guess I wasn't a lot of pain
but but it was it wasn't so bad really
it wasn't that bad it wasn't that you
lost layers of skin didn't you from oh
yeah yeah it was yeah you've got a
broadly a new ear yeah that's a brand
new ear that's pretty good is it how
much of it is actually ears are like
paper they go up they when you fire they
just because there's no boner did you
literally lose an ear well they they re
they REM they made that one so and
you're playing all this down in typical
J Fashion but well you don't I've heard
Dave's version of this and it it sounded
horrific I mean your whole face went up
in FL believe me when rich people catch
on fire the public loves it they love
rich people you know want to hear whiny
celebrities complaining about this is
what happened to me you know so you have
to make a joke out of mean I was doing
regular shows and exra crispy you know I
had all those kind of drugs you your
face is your fortune well it's not my
fortune it's my face right but it's you
know you are Jay sorry did you did you
worry in the period you in h I'm not a
worrier I'm not a stressed guy you know
anything after the tonight's show is
gravy it's really you know my parents
got to see me be successful that was one
of the great joys of my life that they
were proud of me and all that kind of
stuff you know so famously uh you didn't
complain once in the hospital you sent
pizzas to the nurses you meant made
other patients laugh it was all about
other people not you well well yeah I
guess yeah sure why not yeah I guess so
but I mean that's why we going to whine
and complain I mean how many times you
just watch whine celebrities it was a
nightmare and then they asked me to read
for this part it was it's something you
you know the national inquir from page I
think was TVJ in Fireball horror or
something oh yeah Fireball horror but I
I think most people believe if they had
an extra $50,000 they would have no
problems at all and I think people
really most people believe that I think
if you're a happy person and you're s
wealthy
well you're happier but if you're a
terrible person you're not going to be
happy because you're still a terrible
person that's I mean you've interviewed
so many very rich people yes do you see
evidence that money buys
happiness well it doesn't buy happiness
but it could certainly make you happier
I mean it removes worries it removes but
also in a way creates others right yeah
but you can I mean the fact that I could
give scholarships to people or put a
roof on my uncle Louis's house so when I
get home Jay gets the big meatball the
big meatballs for Jay he put the roof on
yeah I get the big I get oh I get the
big meatball so I mean and that kind of
stuff it's it's great fun yeah I Googled
uh how much you were worth yeah do you
know what Google says you're worth I I
I'm sure it's some ridiculous $450
million yeah well I don't know about
that and I'm like wow I mean this garage
alone is going to be worth more than
that yeah that's pretty good do you know
what is worth a garage have you sold all
the cars no it depends because what if
you have to sell them they're not worth
anything you know just it's only worth
money if you have you're selling them
before you have to sell once people
realize oh there's a fire sale you know
they show up fire sale pun attended yeah
yeah soon after you recovered from your
polling yeah incident here you got on a
motorbike and fell off and bust a load
of Bones well no then I a guy had a
court across a driveway without a flag
on it so I came around a corner the sun
was in my eyes and boom it hit me in the
throat and just threw me down on the
ground
and the bike kept going so then I it
just tore my face right here so I had to
call my face guy Hey listen I need Dr
Gman Peter I got I need another face
what' you do I said well the old the
face you got was working great but yeah
it broke so he gave me
another it's been a rough year you you
look it's not that bad you look
relatively okay there people with bigger
problems these are stupid self-inflicted
problems that most people couldn't be
interested in and if you don't do them
in a funny way then you're just a whiny
celebrity complaining you know I've been
incredibly fortunate in my life and if I
can share something with people that'd
be great but no I did to whine and
complain you know nobody wants to hear
how important has Mavis been to you
wonderful me to been married 44 years
yeah I mean that's another thing I never
really you know I I just don't I don't
get these people that just fall into
that trap you know that's another where
low self-esteem is a huge thing because
if this woman wouldn't sleep with me
when I was 25 why would they sleep with
me when I'm
65 but I always meet friends you know
you know I think that hooker really
liked me no she didn't like you okay she
is a hooker she doesn't really like you
it's not a matter of no I think I think
she does the fact you're giving her
$1,500 I think that really is you know
so no I I'm I'm very fortunate I did not
for I have a very good woman and you
know I tried what's the secret of of
longevity do you think in I think that
you know remember telling this to uh
Drew bore I said marry your conscience
find somebody who's the person you wish
you could be my wife does a lot of
charity work and does a lot of involved
with women in Afghanistan and all that
kind of stuff and and women's issues and
things and I said oh I'm kind of selfish
I collect cars and you know so so I'm
going to marry somebody who's a little
better than I am and and it it keeps
everything a check yeah you never had
kids would you have liked to have done I
came back no we just never had kids it's
just never you know something the 44
years went by in a heartbeat you know I
like the idea if I had a gig she could
go with me I don't want to go to a gig
and meet some woman there and then come
back in a year and oh this is Jay junr
you know I no I so I would bring her
with me everywhere I go and and and that
worked out fine do you think you'll ever
stop working well if I have a stroke or
something I suppose but only only if you
were incapacitated well I mean I like
you would voluntarily stop
you still love the oh yeah thrill of
getting a laugh is that really what
you're about oh yeah I think that's the
most that's the most fun thing in the
world really I mean because just it it's
why I travel alone when you travel alone
this is what happens you get famous and
then you have people that do things for
you you know I was telling the story
about I have a place in Rhode Island so
I go to Rhode Island and I always go to
Joe's Pizza okay soone some one of the
guys say hey it's new place Nicholas
Pizza over up and oh I'll try it so okay
I get there and there's a line something
line I gu Jay yeah it's Joe what Joe's
Pizza Hey Joe how you doing goes what
are you doing here he goes something
wrong with our pizza I go no no it's
it's fine he goes what are you doing
here I said I so I just make up a lie I
go well you know I had a coupon I figure
I'm I'm going to try it you know see he
goes coupon we all agreed not to use
coupon he's using coupon okay now now
now I'm in this now I'm in this lie I'm
go well um yeah I don't actually I don't
have the coupon no you said he well no
I'm going to go talk to him don't talk
to him okay now I'm in this stupid line
and it just made me laugh because if I
had somebody getting my pizza for me
that wouldn't have happened you know the
same thing happened do you do you not
have an Entourage at all no I don't I
had no manag I did a I did a gig for
McDonald's you know corporate event so
they gave me like a stack of
Happy Meal coupons I go okay now I don't
like to waste money or throw things so
all right I'll eat lunch at McDonald's
until I you like War Buffett yeah yeah
so I'm in this I'm in this fancy car
that Mercedes SLR where the doors come
up this way so I pull him G and say can
I get two Happy Meals the girl says okay
sir we only allow one happy meal per
visit I said well that's fine he go no
no but I know it's you I can let me talk
to the Magic No don't talk no just just
wait could you pull up come up so so I
pull up right so then the door opens
right so kids come over and the manager
Miss L normally we have a policy then I
hear a kid go HJ Longo he's arguing
about his Happy Meal coupon I'm not
arguing about my Happy Meal coupon I'm
just I look in this half a million
dollar car I like an idiot like fighting
with a a 16-year-old kid at McDonalds
about a Happy Meal it just it just made
me laugh gu goes I I'll give you two
Happy Meal coupons this time but
normally I go yeah I'm okay I'm fine I
gu you it just it just hilarious well I
mean that's what I mean that's that's
what's fun about being on the road just
just odd things happen when you had the
the fireball injury right the phone goes
and it's the president of the United
States Joe Biden right well that's
what's hilarious okay
because prior to that I my friend Steve
were in his
car and it's on the speaker and now
normally when you could get a call from
the
president it's is this General yes it is
are you prepared to take a call from the
president of United States yes I am
please stay on the line so you stay on
the line for a
minute President Bush will pick up the
line Jay oh how are you s from the car
how you ring hello Jay Jay it's
Joe what Joe Joe Biden I oh Joe Biden
president of the United States he goes
yeah how how you feeling I'm I'm okay
sir thank you for calling no no I just
just just made me laugh Jay it's Joe it
just it just made me laugh I thought
that was very fun and didn't you have a
moment when you were with a bunch of
your old mates oh no that what that was
that was Barack Obama and they and they
no here's what happened Barack
Obama I I had seen him on the news and
he's going to run for president the
United States and by that time Hillary
had it Sona I thought well this guy's
pretty car manic let's get him on so we
call him up oh he's thrilled drives to
the T Rent A Car shirt over you know
jacket over his shoulder he sits down
Jay my name is Barack Hussein Obama and
I'm running for president United States
I said oh let's let's see a community
organizer from Chicago black guy was
middle name of Hussein you know you
shouldn't even have to campaign I think
you're going to win and well he thought
that and we hit it off pretty good and
he gave me his cell phone number cuz I
had it from him so and then he came on
one time and president United States and
so this is what happens when you grow up
in a small town you have the same idiot
friend you had when you were in 8th
grade so I'm telling them about some of
my old eighth grade buddies you know so
you know President Obama gave me his
phone up let's call him up I I'm not I'm
not GNA call them up because he's presid
you don't have it nuh uhuh nuh uhuh now
it's it's like you know I said I got it
I said what time is it Okay it's 3 o'cl
or six o'clock all right all right I'll
go our dollar phone you know here Brock
here Mr President yeah Jay L Jay what
can I do for you should I lose this
number Mr President lose the number
Jay just made me laugh my friends are
like yeah pretty stupid I wanted to end
you've come up with so many great
punchlines to jokes over the years and
one of my team and that's the best way
to do it just do the punch lines with no
setup well actually what we wanted to do
was to see if you could remember the
punch lines well probably not so let's
have a go right cuz they're going to be
funny whether you can or not but we did
thousand we did I know thousands of
tomato so unfortunately for you one of
my team is a massive jeno fan all right
and so he's crafted carefully these and
seeing wants to see if you can remember
the punch you're not famous
until oh I don't know I don't know what
that my mother has heard of you oh that
my picture yeah that's well that was my
mother my mother never never heard of
anybody you know if God had wanted us to
vote he'd would have given us candidate
correct there are now more obese people
in the United States than there are
overweight people I think it's safe to
say I don't know what was that after all
these years Diet Coke is a complete
failure
yeah today is Valentine's Day or as men
like to call it hostage day some was
extortion day extortion day okay and in
America we like everyone to know about
the good work we're doing
Anonymous that's my favorite thing too
that people they want everyone to know
we're doing this work anonymously yeah
yeah it's been a real pleasure well
thank you my friend great to see you
good
talking